when i started this youtube channel four
years ago most react developers would
have laughed at the idea of using
something like typescript
you should try it nah bro like why would
you take your beautiful functional
javascript and bloat it with a bunch of
type definitions that make it look like
the real java
i was very skeptical of it myself when i
first started using it in an angular
project in 2017.
now maybe it's just the stockholm
syndrome talking but after using it i've
never wanted to go back but i don't
think i'm alone because it was the
second most loved technology on the 2020
stackoverflow survey
in today's video you'll learn everything
you need to know to get started with
typescript and react
but more importantly we'll talk about
why or why not you should use it because
there's a good case to be made for both
sides of that argument
if you're new here like and subscribe
and become a pro member at fireship io
to get access to my full next js react
course
to decide whether or not you want to use
typescript let's take a look at two
different projects side by side
one with typescript and one without
there are many different ways to add
typescript to a react app
in this case i'm using the create react
app tool but specifying the typescript
template the docs also have instructions
for adding it to an existing project or
you can learn how to set it up in
next.js in my course
if we look at the file system on these
two projects side by side the most
obvious difference is that the
typescript project has files ending in
ts or dot tsx but the weird thing is
that if we look inside one of these
files
the code is exactly the same as the
javascript file and that actually brings
up a good question what is typescript if
my code is exactly the same
typescript as a language is a superset
of javascript that means vanilla
javascript
is also 100 valid typescript in other
words it just adds extra optional
features on top of regular javascript
the relationship between
scss and css is the same as typescript
and javascript and that's really cool
because it means you don't really have
to learn anything to get started with it
but here's the catch browsers don't know
how to run typescript code what is this
crap
which means that we need a compiler to
take our typescript code
and transpile it or compile it down to
regular javascript in our ts project
you'll notice a special file called ts
config its purpose
is to customize the behavior of the
compiler which itself is able to take
your typescript code
and convert it to any flavor of
javascript that you want to run in the
browser
compilers are really cool because they
allow you to use special features
and modern javascript syntax without
having to worry whether or not that
code's going to be supported on old
legacy browsers
the drawback is that you now have this
giant configuration file to worry about
normally everything just works but when
it doesn't you have to google all these
different options and figure out what
they do
many of the options are related to how
strict typescript is with its type
checking rules
and i'd highly recommend making it as
strict as possible by putting strict
mode to true
that'll make your code initially more
difficult to write but in the long run
it makes refactoring and collaborating
with other developers way easier
another important option is target which
is the flavor of javascript that
typescript will compile your code too
es5 is the 2009 version of javascript
but your codebase can write 2021
javascript
sounds amazing but you really need
typescript to do that under the hood the
javascript version of create react app
uses a compiler called
babel that does the exact same thing so
the bottom line is that you can write
modern
code in both a react js or ts project
now one thing you'll often hear
typescript developers say is that it
helps them catch silly bugs in
development before they become huge
disasters in production
let's take a look at an example to see
if that's true or not in the javascript
project i have some state that starts
off as an empty object
now somewhere else i might reference
that object and try to access a deeply
nested property on it
that looks like valid code but when we
run the app we get an error that it
cannot read that property
bugs like this get shipped to production
all the time but if we try to do the
same thing in typescript it's like a
goddamn precog that lets us know the
error exists before the app even runs i
really appreciate that because i make
silly mistakes like that all the time
but keep in mind that it doesn't replace
test driven development it can detect
poorly structured code in advance
but can't detect bad logic but now let's
look at the most important feature of
typescript
its type system and the pros and cons of
using it if we build a functional
component in javascript you'll notice
that it has a type of jsx element
in addition if we reference props they
automatically have a type of any
that's a pretty vague type definition
overall in typescript we can be much
more explicit about what our code
actually is
react has a built-in type called fc
which stands for function component and
we can assign that type to the component
using a colon followed by the type that
tells the compiler the shape of this
code which will throw an error for
anything that's not a valid prop
and autocomplete everything else by
default the only known react prop is
children
but we can define the shape of our own
props using a typescript interface
an interface allows you to define the
shape of an object by matching a
property name
to a type like here we have an interface
called cool props
that should be an object with two
properties one of which is a number and
the other a string
in its current form the interface will
make these properties required on the
object
but you can make them optional by adding
a question mark after the property name
we can now take this interface and pass
it to the function component
type by wrapping it in angle brackets
this is like saying we have a function
component that also includes props of
its own custom shape
and now we get really useful
intellisense on any props when working
with this component
and it also guarantees that we use the
required props when working with this
component in jsx
however that did come at a pretty
significant cost we've added a lot of
boilerplate to the code base without
adding any new functionality for the
user
now it is possible to bypass type
checking whenever you want by simply
adding the any type
that allows you to opt out of typescript
but also negates all of its benefits
it's also worth noting that typescript
can provide automatic documentation for
your code
because your editor will automatically
pick up the type definitions
so anybody using your code will get
intellisense on the shape and purpose of
it and that's way way more efficient
than having to go read some
documentation online
now in many cases typescript can
automatically infer the type
without you having to add any additional
code to the code base for example
you might want to strongly type the use
state hook however the angle brackets
may not be necessary here because if you
have a default value of a string
you don't need to give it an explicit
type it'll have a string type
automatically
and if you try to change it to a value
that's not a string you'll get that
precog error in vs code so that's pretty
nice but is typescript really worth it
it's managed by microsoft enterprise
loves it but some guy on the internet
said it only catches 15
of bugs while airbnb said it catches 38
percent of bugs would you rather write
more code or would you rather be more
confident in the code you do write would
you rather look at your documentation on
a website or would you rather have it be
automatic in your editor would you
rather write faster code now or deal
with chaotic refactoring later do your
friends and family love it or do they
hate it these are all trade-offs that
you need to think about but in my
opinion
the answer to should you use typescript
with react is obviously